Hello Freak bitches.
We're not like in a,
I'm not like in a position where I'm going
to have an actual battle with someone
yet.
I don't know.
You're right,
but but,
but for competition,
no self defense.
Self defense.
I mean like I like,
see then you can't say that because that
could happen on the way to the grocery
store.
Oh my God.
You can run into some crazy messed
up chick wants a fucking do get out.
Literally
like we're doing this.
I wish I had the fucking
manpower literally to like
we were in Nashville like
two weeks ago for Americana Fest.
We're playing this festival and we were
driving under this bridge and there were
these two guys beating the fuck out of
each other in the middle of the street.
It was like a bottle over the face.
This one guy was choking
the other guy and anchor.
No,
terrible.
It was sloppy.
Crackhead,
bullshit.
Main puzzles.
It was like,
obviously we called the police,
but like I had this
moment where I was like,
I wanted to do something.
I'm like,
what the fuck can I do?
And I was literally the leaned
out the window and I went stop.
I didn't know what to do.
And I called the police.
But like if I were a new job,
like you
definitely stayed in my car,
right?
100%
if you're driving by two people
beating the fuck out of each other,
you are not there.
Okay.
You were in a car just because
it's right in front of you.
That shit could be a hundred
miles away in less and less.
There's someone in that
mixture that needs you.
Like if there's someone who's small
and they get beaten up by someone big,
then everything changes.
But if it's too fucking dude
chill from the other day,
they're fighting in the street fucking
so my point is don't always stop.
Just kiss already.
Don't always stop.
Sometimes you get to elect two
dudes beat each of the day.
It's better for everybody.
Certain people,
it's fine.
Just give him both rocks
and push them near the edge.
Go
let them fall and keep coal mining.
You got to keep moving.
Okay.
Genes need to flourish.
They need to find better
streams of diversity.
That's what I'm saying,
man,
don't always stop fights.
And what I've realized is when they,
when they've recognize you as a threat,
when they identify you as
somebody who could do them damage,
they start going on maneuvers trying
to find out everything about it.
You're trying to find out what the worst
stuff they have on you is so that he
can dismiss you as a bigot or a
sexist or a Neo Nazi or whatever.
They can come up with anything they can
grasp out because their strategy is to
dismiss the,
is to dismiss the speaker by
attacking the speakers credibility.
Because that way they never have to even
consider the merits of the argument.
Yes.
They haven't been able to do that with me.
Um,
which is why feminists
now refuse to bait me,
debate me on TV because
they know they'll lose.
Um,
they calm,
bring out,
well they can't bring out,
they've got this battery of dismissing
of a dismissal tactics that they've
amassed over the last 30 years and
they've got so complacent because they've
never had,
you know,
a Sassy gay person.
And come up and say it,
you're talking bullshit and you're
hurting men and here are the facts.
They've never had it before.
So they've never built up
an arsenal to fight it.
Um,
you know,
so this is,
this is why I went and while Cook I'll
keep winning because they don't really
know how to deal with an
argument on its own merits.
And in any case,
of course the facts are on our side.
Well,
it's also this conversation that
we're having right now is about war.
You're saying winning and losing and
they're taking tactics and strategies to
look up dirt on the opposition.
They're going,
they're treating.
This is,
it's,
this is an ideological war is not a
debate about the facts of the issue.
And I think that's part of it because
the left has always seen this as a war.
And the gender warriors,
you know,
have always been warriors.
They've always seen
this in strategic terms.
I'm not sure.
People on Conservatives and naturally
more self effacing conservatives tend to
be a little bit cool,
a little bit more chill about things
they kind of don't really want to get of.
How do you explain?
I think they get very angry about things.
Ted Cruz,
what am I saying?
Old Conservatives,
but he explained,
what's her name?
Pailin chick.
Sarah Pailin.
How to explain that.
These are the,
these are the outline is that even most
conservatives find these people a bit
much.
How could be,
I think that guy's in his,
in the end.
Who knows how these much fatter
now he was hopping when last time.
I mean,
you know,
for like a lazy Christian TV gigs,
so fat he got so far,
I cannot vote for anyone.
That phenomena of rock and rolling.
I Want Marco Rubio just because he's hot.
If we call out Trump,
then I won't regret it.
I don't think.
I think people are silly.
So whether or not it's a conservative
thing or a liberal thing,
I think there's a vast majority of people
that aren't not very good at looking
at themselves.
And they're not very good at looking
at the momentum of their actions.
They just think that they're right
because this is what they've,
they've been saying for so long.
And I think that's one of the most
horrific things about these conversations
with these women.
Get in with you about,
cause like when,
when they're talking about what
they think are social constructs,
things like gender identities
and the way people be.
And when you shatter that with the facts,
they're looking for some other weapons
and there's nothing there or you see it
in their eyes.
You know,
cause it's not really a
debate about the idea itself.
It's just not what,
it's not.
What it's about is gender warfare.
That's why people like Christina Hoff
summers called them gender warriors
because these aren't people who want
any kind of social justice as they say.
These are people who just hate men,
will just hate men.
They want to hurt men.
Um,
they don't want to quality for women.
They want to,
they want superiority for women.
Whether it's architected into
the education system or you know,
affirmative action or whatever it is.
They don't want quality.
They want superiority.
And fundamentally,
a lot of this,
you know,
these,
these crazy extremist,
you know,
uh,
progressive third wave feminists,
today's version of feminism.
It basically boils down to [inaudible]
and it takes a gay guy because it's so
dangerous for men to even
broach this subject anymore.
And any man,
a mainstream job puts that at risk by
even talking on the subject no matter what
his opinion is.
Um,
it takes a gay guy to go on,
you know,
Sky News in the UK and say,
I'm sorry,
the facts are not on your side and
what you're doing is damaging to women.
Um,
it's to me really an indictment on a,
on debate in our public square that it
is so dangerous for a man to even express
an opinion on this subject that it takes
a fact they're going to stick up for,
for heterosexuals.
If other men could say this,
they would be,
but they can't because they would
run the risk of their careers.
Feminists always talking
about silencing the people.
Icy silence to men,
but we don't,
there's no like established
number that everybody knows like,
oh,
if you eat this,
you how many milligrams are you had 10 oh,
you're fine.
There's because of the
fact that it's illegal.
There's all this guessing and you gotta.
It takes a long time to figure it out.
You've got to talk to a bunch of
different people and get answers.
Don't talk to Joey Diaz throwing off
the curve or don't worry about a cop
soccer.
Even though the one you're
going to walk on ice,
you might as well dance.
I saw him the other day
on periscope just eating.
He's like,
all right,
here,
take this,
and he's like,
they're eating just tons of
edibles and then they're like,
all right,
you [inaudible] you've never done acid.
Well,
open up your tongue here
and they just drop acid.
Eight ish.
Yeah.
Joey goes so deep.
He's not even experiencing reality as
we know it because reality is just very
different right now.
Where to lead.
This guy's like,
oh,
I guess ass eating that much as normal.
He enjoys it.
He's turning him into a Jody is.
Yeah,
but listen man,
think about if you're Li,
right.
Nice kid.
Very smart guy.
He's a sweetheart.
Funny on the show.
And this fucker has stumbled into a
partnership with the funniest man that's
ever lived.
So he has this podcast,
the funniest man that's ever lived.
What is the funniest
man that's ever lived?
Do he doses them every day?
Joey Diaz doses that guy with
like 500 milligram Chiba Chews.
He'll take the wrapper off of a
fucking 200 milligram Chiba Chew,
put a 500 milligram in their
rapid wrap it handed to him,
eat a dog the mile,
the mile done line about the
fucking number two hundreds normal.
The line about the number,
they say 200 get the fuck outta here to
Honda with your fucking faggy 200 I had
like a 40 the other day
or something like that.
I was fucked up out of book.
I can't believe they let Lee
thinks 200 is a normal number,
you know?
Yeah.
Those guys go deep.
He had to death stars the other day too,
to death stars too.
I've never even heard of anybody
eating two of those things.
Do you ever heard of the death star?
Oh my God.
Is it?
There's some fucking thing that
these guys in northern California,
Maine,
I think the same guys who
make the gummy bears make the,
uh,
the death stars and they're
supposed to be so bad.
Joey was running,
trying to give one to Alex Jones
last time we were in Austin together.
Where's Alex Jones?
I got to get him one of these desktops.
Joe Rogan.
I'm going to get them
one of these desktops.
I'm gonna fuck him up.
Last time he had like a of bread
gummy where he was cutting
slices for amazing.
I gotta make slice you off on and
like,
you ready to fucking Deli with them?
Hey,
you got to try this.
No pressure.
I got this new pursued.
All this fucking guy knows
on a make a good pursuit.
Okay.